[Musica]
come volete che racconti questa storia
non so raccontare ma posso dire che su
viverla
vorrei raccontare un'altra storia di
questo sud allora ho cominciato a
pensare che il sud e qualcuno non volevo
più che il sud rimanesse nel concetto
allora ha cominciato a parlare con il
sud
ho cominciato a immaginarlo
e allora per immaginarlo gli ho dato
corpo e la terra su cui camminiamo gli
ho dato un cuore e ho cominciato a
vedere il cuore di che cosa è fatto i
sentimenti di questo sud di questo
personaggio di questo qualcuno di che
cosa è fatto e ho cominciato ad amare ad
essere amata e lì è stato molto
difficile essere amati dal sud è stato
il mio più grande scoglio
poi ho cominciato a immaginare che
questo sud a un intelligenza come
chiunque abbiamo un intelligenza abbiamo
un corpo
abbiamo un cuore
allora è facile rivolgersi a qualcuno
che smette di essere un concetto e
diventa qualcuno
e mi sono ricordata di quando invece
sono andata via da questo sud sono
andate via sbattendo la porta perché al
sud non si può fare nulla
come tutti quanti sono andate a vivere
fuori a fare l'università sono andata a
vivere a roma poi roma era troppo
periferica rispetto al mondo volevo
attraversare il mondo e conoscere il
mondo
e allora sono andato a vivere a parigi
parigi era nel centro dell'europa e e
quello andava bene e ho dimenticato il
sud ho cominciato davvero dimenticare il
sud perché era era nel concetto e in
quel concetto viveva l'arrabbiatura
e poi
questo qualcuno questo sud si è
affacciato di nuovo ha cominciato ad
amarmi
e ricordo bene quando sono andata via da
parigi
immaginavo tornare al sud può essere una
cosa un salto nel vuoto può essere
qualcosa che vi farà pentire per tutta
la mia vita di questa scelta e mi sono
consolata pensando
spero che non ci siano francesi in sala
i francesi non conoscono le barzellette
in francia non ci sono le barzellette
nessuno sorridere si raccontano molte
storie ma non ci sono le barzellette
allora ho pensato torno in italia li
sanno raccontare le barzellette sanno
ridere e poi ho pensato no tornò nel sud
e allora il rapporto è cambiato
completamente cambiato e ho
[Musica]
immaginato
qual era la soluzione dentro di me non
volevo più che il sud fosse un problema
ma una soluzione un'opportunità e la
prima cosa che è venuta
così come un ideale idee vengono da dio
si dice no e la grazia è qualcosa che ti
tocca non era frutto di un ragionamento
ma questa idea era una storia allora
anche la storia ha smesso di essere un
concetto è diventata qualcuno le storie
sono viventi e le storie cambiano il
modo in cui noi pensiamo a noi stessi in
cui raccontiamo la nostra storia a noi
stessi quando noi parliamo
qualcuno ci ascolta fuori ma qualcuno ci
ascolta anche dentro se io racconta una
storia brutta di me qualcuno dentro di
me la svolta e finisce per crederci per
identificarsi con quella storia allora
le storie sono diventate il mio lavoro
prima con il teatro e adesso con il
cinema le storie sono viventi e le
storie cambiano la percezione che noi
abbiamo di noi stessi
quante volte quando guardiamo un film ma
ci identifichiamo con quelle storie
quante volte abbiamo amato si i
personaggi ma i personaggi erano il
conduttore di una storia
quante volte abbiamo imparato a
raccontare storie
guardando un film oppure andando a
vedere uno spettacolo in teatro questo è
un luogo è una sorta di incubatore qui
nascono le storie così accade anche
nelle sale cinematografiche
se noi immaginiamo le storie come
qualcuno che vive
possiamo parlare con quella storia e
possiamo parlare con la nostra storia
quando ho deciso di tornare a vivere
al sud ho cominciato a cambiare la
storia di me una persona una ragazza
giovane che era andata via sbattendo la
porta e che invece ritorna
volendo fare qualcosa e cominciare a
farlo attraverso le storie è diventata
una grandissima avventura
la fisica quantistica ci racconta negli
ultimi decenni ci racconta un fatto che
non era mai stato immaginato da nessun
essere umano
l'osservatore cambia il risultato
dell'esperimento questo ci racconta la
fisica quantistica
allora questo esperimento se è la mia
vita se la mia storia può essere
cambiato se io osservo la mia vita la
mia storia
posso cambiare a seconda di quella che è
la percezione della mia vita questo fa
il cinema questo fa il teatro ma il
cinema in particolare perché il cinema
ha un impatto immediato su tutti i sensi
e quelli che mancano gli
ricostruisce allora il mio la mia grande
scoperta
finora fin qui fino a questo punto della
mia vita è quella che riguarda le storie
una storia del sud è sicuramente ma
riguarda il modo in cui le storie
possono cambiarti la vita allora
vi racconto una storia una storia
piccola una storiella c'era una volta un
narratore questo narratore voleva
raccontare la più bella storia del mondo
allora si mise ii e cominciò a
immaginare questa storia scriverla poi a
recitarla puoi approvarla e quando
quando penso di aver messo insieme la
più bella storia del mondo andò in una
piazza sali su una panchina cominciò a
raccontarla e tutta la gente arrivava
volevo ascoltare questa storia che in
effetti era bellissima e secondo lui era
la più bella storia del mondo e allora
il pubblico applaudiva poi il giorno
dopo lui tornava di nuovo in quella
piazza a raccontare sempre quella storia
la più bella storia del mondo
il pubblico di nuovo applaudiva poi gli
faceva i complimenti e si congratulava e
poi andava via e lui di nuovo il giorno
dopo ancora nel pomeriggio nella stessa
storia nella stessa ora raccontava la
stessa storia
e poi ancora poi ancora e poi ancora
finché nella piazza non arriva più
nessuno perché lui raccontava sempre la
stessa storia
finché arrivò un giorno non c'era più
nessuno
ma lui continuava a raccontare la sua
storia la sua bellissima storia la più
bella storia del mondo
e allora si avvicinò un signore egli
disse ma ma guarda ma sei un illuso ma
non ti rendi conto che non c'è più
nessuno sa chi stai raccontando questa
storia ma credi che con le tue storie
puoi cambiare il mondo e allora lui
tutto contento felice come una pasqua
gli rispose no non voglio racconto
cambiare il mondo non racconto storie
per cambiare il mondo racconto storia
affinché il mondo non cambi me e questa
per me è una
è una storia che mi è entrata dentro
perché mi ha insegnato che io posso
cambiare il racconto che faccio di me e
nel cambiare il racconto che faccio di
me posso coinvolgere gli altri posso
invitare gli altri perché è bello non
fare il viaggio da soli
e bello immaginare che quando con gli
altri partecipano a questa tua storia si
crea una storia più grande una storia
più magica
questo accade nel cinema quando si
raccontano le storie e partecipa il
pubblico in questo racconto si crea
qualcosa di più magico
l'osservatore cambia il risultato
dell'esperimento e fateci caso quando
voi andate al cinema lo stesso film non
lo vedete con gli stessi occhi non lo
vivete con le stesse emozioni non
comprendete gli stessi dettaglio la
stessa sequenza narrativa
rispetto a quando il film lo vedete a
casa vostra sicuramente più comodo ma
la storia è vivente e vive insieme a
tutte le persone che partecipano nella
sala cinematografica a creare un sogno
quella è la storia è un sogno che
diventa realtà perché le persone
la incarnano questo è il cinema e queste
sono le storie
[Applauso]